now is everybody ready for the speed run
we're gonna play one or two games we're
gonna play five minutes again we're
almost up to fifteen hundred
this is where things get interesting
let's get on with it ladies and
gentlemen
[Music]
i'm gonna raise the sparkling water to
my man trav man with
15 subs to the community what a freaking
beast
that guy is we have a philidor now as we
go
as we know in the philadelphia we want
to open up the center and develop our
pieces
i'm playing this fast because we've okay
what is he doing
thank you ruffle for the front now this
is a great example of
our opponent doing something weird and
we don't need to especially modify our
strategy
because he's doing anything weird he's
not attacking our knight we don't need
to move it
where should we develop this bishop now
e5 would be a little bit too much we
would just give up the pawn
so in this case we haven't even barely
begun our development let's
uh let's develop our pieces to active
squares
there's just nothing that we need to do
differently because he's put a bishop on
f6 so let's just develop all of our
pieces let's put the bishop on e3 to
lend
uh further support to this knight on d4
now we've
developed all of our pieces and the time
has come for us to start expanding
a little bit on another side of the
board uh what move comes to mind there's
a very typical move in such positions
where we expand a little bit on the
queen side we create like a pawn
umbrella
and this pawn umbrella can be used for
various purposes
now a4 is usually good only if you're
sort of preventing b5
so let's play f4 to expand a little bit
on the king's side
okay so now is a great time to play a4
to prevent him sorry to prevent him from
playing b5 okay
now our pieces are sufficiently active
to where we can basically now go for his
throat
and uh when i say go for his throat what
i really mean is
is accumulate pieces on the king's side
and and go for an attack
uh and when you hear the word accumulate
pieces the first piece you should
immediately think of is the queen
some people are probably thinking about
queen f3 but that's not the most active
score for the queen always look for the
most
active squares for each one of your
pieces what is the most active square
for the queen
queen g4 walks right into that pin
yeah a lot of people saying queen g4 but
be very careful about walking into a
discovery
there is a square that i think some
people are are worried about putting the
queen on
that is the square h5 but there's no no
need to worry
because how can the queen be touched the
queen cannot be touched here it can
barely be attacked
and um i know a lot of people i know
i've warned people not to play around
with their queen particularly early on
but we've reached a level where there
are exceptions to the rule and here
the queen is perfectly invulnerable
let's keep the bishop on this diagonal
and i will explain in a moment
after the game why bishop b3 is inferior
thank you again travman for that massive
hype
okay where should we go where should the
snipe go
think not about the next move think
about the night's ultimate destination
this is going to help people find the
right move knight f5 is normal that's
fine but
i don't really want to allow it to be
taken
i'm going to play the move knight to f3
now where is the knight
where is the knight going ultimately in
the end
it's potentially going to g5 but
emphasis
on the word potentially we're not going
to g5 yet we're going to try to wait for
black to take
our knight on c3 okay so black is played
c4
which shuts out our bishop why is c4 a
thing
because of the knight on v6 should we
take the knight on b6 no because we
don't want to give away this beautiful
bishop which is holding everything
together
so let us play a5 that's why we played
a4 so to be able to chase the knight
away so that the bishop can rejoin the
game when bishop takes
c4 and then we're going to be up a pawn
and all of our pieces are going to be in
the game
we're going to be in great shape okay
final destination yes great movie
yeah remove the defender but don't rush
to take the defender sometimes you can
just remove it
this is another very typical example of
overloading the knight is protected by
the pawn
this pawn on d6 is just visually very
weak
how can this pawn on d6 be distracted
rook d1 is absolutely a good move but
we can also play a little bit more
directly with the movie five just
immediately sort of
removing the defender from oh god i got
my queen trapped
and i just made a big blunder my i just
made a big blunder actually
so knight f4 traps the queen
knight f4 traps the queen yep queen has
no squares
but how do you get out of this situation
you put on your daniel nereditsky hat
and you're like okay let's sack the
queen
knight 65
yeah so this happens i mean i make
mistakes too
and i just made a big one
but we have to maintain our composure
and keep looking for chances
okay
yeah i might have to okay so uh he's
made a mistake by playing 96
and the simple truth is that we've given
up our queen but we have
a tremendous amount of material in
return for the queen we have a very
active position
and um first of all i don't want anybody
to be under the illusion that i don't
make mistakes or that i
am somehow perfect so
in what form is our compensation for the
queen first of all let's be realistic we
have a rook and a piece for the queen
that's already basically equivalent
second of all i'll look at all of our
pieces
they are perfectly centrally placed and
now
we can already win the queen back with
what move
we can basically just crash through with
what move we don't need to play knight
takes f7 but why not rook takes f7 just
immediately taking it to the queen
so from the time that we blundered the
queen
i blundered the queen to the time that
we're winning
is about three moves and
[Music]
that's just the reality the queen before
does this create any actual threats
does it attack the bishop does this move
it actually attack the bishop
no we can just continue activating all
of our pieces we can bring the other
rook into the game
we can start thinking about how to
deliver checkmate here
which is not going to be easy he takes
the pawn now this guy is very good
um let me think please oh
hmm i did actually think
absolutely beautiful idea oh my good
oh my goodness there's some beautiful
beautiful concepts
okay let's just hope he takes them one
sec i i gotta do this just because
of chess beauty no and he sees it
oh okay one sec nice sorry he saw
the correct night to take okay now i'm
playing with some serious fire
now i'm playing with some serious fire
uh but his king is in is in huge trouble
here obviously
we're going to create the possibility
for a discovered check
we'll come
check and we are in great shape he's got
to take the knight and give up his queen
he doesn't
what do we do what does white do in this
position
rook f8 and it's mate so we're good
we have enough pieces to deliver
checkmate with
and um this guy was good i mean this guy
was i actually came up with a really
nice tactical idea instead of this i'll
show you guys
okay so that was close
and first of all these kinds of sudden
things
i also tend to miss so what did i miss
here like i grabbed the knight
immediately because i thought this one a
piece but i didn't calculate deeply
enough
the move f takes e5 would have been
completely winning because
we didn't even need the extra night i
mean our just because their position is
just completely overwhelming
uh but let's see the end of the game i
know people are excited
so this move96 i saw a really really
beautiful mate
if he played queen takes e5 which i
expected from him
let's find this mate together what do
you guys think is the first move of the
combination there is really only one
possible check
if you can notice the pin check
king can't take the rook because of the
rook knight can't take because bishop
is spinning okay okay let's continue
um it doesn't even work uh
it's just bad so yeah guys this is a bad
calculation honestly
i'm out of gas for today probably we'd
have to go rook h8 give up the rook and
then win the queen back and white is
white is better uh but this is this is
not what i had in mind initially that's
just sort of the backup option
the line that i had in mind initially
is bishop d3 rook f7
and here i miscalculated thinking
thinking that my bishop was still on c4
now if the bishop was on c4
then white would have a beautiful mating
idea
what would be white's mating idea in
this position
and this is just me running out of gas
unfortunately
and miscalculating but nonetheless white
to play in this position
yeah okay sacking the rook
in order to pave the way for the bishop
and that paves the way for the night
this is checkmate
very unusual checkmating idea by the way
so there are some cool stuff here
there is some cool stuff here but sadly
i lost my objectivity completely and so
the game was close but other than that
everything else we did was perfectly
understandable
yeah so so this is a very instructive
mistake like do not
rush with anything because disaster can
strike
at any moment in any position there's it
doesn't make any sense that this
uh that this that this traps the queen
but but it does
uh and and that's just the way the chest
works it sometimes doesn't make too much
sense
by the way the best um
the best move for black here would have
been queen to g5
forking the knight and threatening
checkmate on g2 this would have put me
in tremendous trouble
so that's how gm's lose lose games to
weaker opponents is like you get sloppy
you fall asleep and
can happen to anybody all right guys
last game
and then i'm gonna go to sleep because
i'm quite exhausted
but let's play one last game
and i will stream again tomorrow fifth
sixteen hundred
let's go let's play a silicon again that
bishop c4 is
all right so this guy is playing very
weird chess
b3 he's wasting time trying to
fianchetto his bishop which doesn't make
too much sense let's just
develop our knights and then you guys
know the drill in such positions the
best thing to do
is to play e6 and prepare the move d5
and uh he's already lost a bishop
because his bishop will
his bishop is only one square but that
square is going to it results in the
loss of a bishop and the loss of the
game
this is a tactical pattern that i think
most of you probably are aware of
uh well the fiance doesn't make sense
because it's just weird to develop
bishops in this way
also there is the chess principle nights
before bishops
and uh he's kind of violating that now
we're going to force him to develop his
knight and what do we do with this night
what do we do with this the id4 yeah
exactly winning the night
yeah we don't care about that he's got
to give up a pawn for the night
uh and we're just going to be up a full
piece for no compensation okay
and this stuff people will try to do to
you we can play bishop e7 we can play
bishop b6 it doesn't matter
as long as we can cover the check and we
he doesn't even
give get a pawn for the uh for the night
now i'm gonna ask people a trick
question
can we castle is it possible to castle
here
don't get caught it is actually possible
to castle
because after queen takes c7 we play
rook to e8 and we pin the king
right so i've told people this before
like sometimes our brain tells us
something is impossible
but before concluding that by the way
defending the bishop before concluding
that it's impossible
we have to ask ourselves what happens if
we do it anyway and that awakens in you
the possibility of finding
something like this okay
so we are up a full piece
there's nothing else to really talk
about now we can just go about trading
as many pieces as possible
queen on e3 is very clearly vulnerable
we can attack this queen by shifting the
knight over to d5
opening up a channel between the bishops
we can also take the knight so we can
start trading pieces here
and ruining his pawn structure the game
is essentially over
and um yeah
we're going to take all of the pieces
we're going to be up at night and his
king's side is going to be
completely ruined and we are going to
approach
1500
so i'm anticipating either resignation
or he's gonna
play a couple more moves
these triple pawns remind me of the
magnus versus tara yeah
some people might be disappointed by the
fact that we have triple pawn okay now
we win another piece we take the knight
removing the defender from the bishop
and then we're going to be up two pieces
the rest you guys basically know the
drill we're going to put a rook on the 8
we don't forget
to deploy the remainder of our pieces in
a situation when we have a lot of extra
material he simply resigns
in a perfect game to end today's
speed run yeah so just up two pieces now
why is it a bad idea to film kettle the
bishop here
first of all the move d3 people should
rule out uh because
because the bishop has no way back uh
and and and to do such a thing
particularly when your bishop has come
outside the pawn chain is just very
dangerous
uh so he should have at least probably
defended this pawn or maybe even not
defended it just got bishop b2
uh but but after d3 e6 it's already very
difficult to save the bishop
he has to do something like d4 or b4
that's obviously very undesirable
so this would have been
yeah this move is is almost a killer
almost immediately